Friday assembly at Robert clack school
in Dagenham a special guest and a
standing ovation
it was Megan's first solo event since
announcing she wants to step away from
royal life and she was very clear about
what she does want to focus on for me it
was incredibly important to be with the
women of our future and that is all of
you young women here as well as the
young men who play a very large part in
this but she wanted to share her
platform it is obvious that here she's
made a real connection despite the
sometimes negative press I did not even
kind of speak so I was very very
pleasantly surprised today I think it
was just lovely to hear voice just in
person for somebody from that sort of
background to come to our school to come
to our borough and to recognize it as an
important enough place to come to is
really quite nice while spending time
with the pupils was important
she also chose Dagenham because of women
like Geraldine dear who in 1968 went on
strike at the Ford Motor Factory for
equal pay with a reaction like this it
is hardly surprising that news of
Megan's appearance actually leaked on
Friday the reason that we're only
talking about Megan's visit now is
because the palace didn't want to
overshadow other events that Royals were
attending on Friday the thing is with
the Sussex is at the moment anything
that they do is a distraction on
Saturday night they were again out as a
couple or Monday we're going to see them
for the first time with other members of
the royal family for the Commonwealth
Day service and no prizes for guessing
who will again be the star attraction
Rhiannon Mills Sky News
[Applause]